so what I want to do here is have a
conversation about Ajax and what I'm
hoping is that at the end of all this
you'll have a strong understanding of
his character as well as the role he
played in the early life of Deadpool as
a villain
covered in Deadpool Volume one issues 14
through 16 Deadpool and death annual
number one as well as issues 18 and 19
Ajax's first appearance of model comics
initially came as a byproduct of the
standard method of comic book
storytelling what I mean here is that
for those of you who are currently
reading Deadpool a common trend you may
notice is that he doesn't usually have
an arch-villain instead Wade gets
himself involved in a series of
escapades and while a villain may be
present
unlike the relationship between the
x-men and Magneto or Captain America and
Red Skull deadpool does not have a
villain all his own the reason for this
is that Wade is designed to break away
from the standard traditions of
storytelling and comics by breaking the
fourth wall poking fun of the story or
being a parody of other characters
however in his original publications
this was not the case because Deadpool
in the 1990s was still coming into his
own under the writing of Joe Kelly a
kind of balancing act had to be played
in order to ensure the traditional comic
book fans didn't run away from the new
concept but new comic book fans could
enjoy the comedic style of Kelly to this
end
Ajax was provided as a character that
could fill the niche of being Deadpool's
arch-nemesis allowing the comic to fit
in with the standard method of
storytelling at the time while
simultaneously allowing Kelly to try new
things coming out of the conclusion of a
two-part story in Deadpool issue number
13 called the drowning man at its end
one of Wade's earliest enemy's name T
Ray had stabbed her to the heart leaving
him for dead while issue number 14 would
continue on from this and focus largely
on weasel and blind al Kelly set the
stage for the introduction of Ajax by
having a visit a character named Jacques
as a story was originally written the
situation seemed to appear out of thin
air with Ajax demanding to know where
Deadpool was and while Jacques was
unable to provide an answer the scenario
unfolded revealing that Jacques was
previously a participant of the Weapon X
project and Ajax was systematically
tracking down those who escaped and
killing them following this Ajax's next
appearance came in issue number 15 where
he visited a man named Todd again as a
cameo in the story similar to issue
number 14 Todd appeared to have been one
of the experiments of Weapon X who had
somehow escaped a facility and took to
the wilderness of Canada setting up a
home for himself and practicing his use
of handcrafted weapons after learning
about the death of Jacques the death of
Todd came off
channel with Ajax simply shown to a rip
to cybernetic arms off where issue 16 is
17 would see the trend continue with
Ajax killing off surviving members of
the web annexed program during his hunt
for Deadpool at the conclusion of
mission number 17 and while apologizing
to blind Al for locking her and weasel
in a torture room and accidentally
forgetting about them Deadpool was
teleported to a mountainside and thrown
off by Ajax with the intention of
killing him and so experiencing his own
death by leaving his physical body and
encountering mistress death after some
quips and commenting on death's cold
touch the store begins to jump back and
forth between waits conversations with
death and his history with Ajax at a
sidetrack for a second if you didn't see
yesterday's video on the origins of
Weapon X which you'll find in the
description we discussed the following
Wolverines escape from the Weapon X
facility and into the wilds because his
healing factor made it possible for him
to survive the adamantium bonding
process the goal of the Weapon X program
became twofold recapture Wolverine and
develop super soldiers using his healing
factor to this end in the x-men origin
story for Deadpool Wade had developed
cancer and was offered a cure with Webb
enacts taking advantage of the offer he
was provided a more amped up form of
Wolverines human factor which cured his
cancer but at the cost of riddling his
body with scar tissue making him hideous
because the purpose of Weapon X creating
super soldiers was to use them as a
means to operate as moles and various
organizations and governments with Wade
being so physically deformed he was
considered to be a failure and has
within a facility called the workshop
ran by immerse kill brew with Ajax
acting as the head of security at the
outside of the comic and going into his
time in the workshop
Joe Kelly provides us with a scenario
where the other members of the facility
more or less function freely but live at
the behest of kill brew and Ajax what I
mean here is that the inmates are
allowed to congregate and socialize but
also have what's referred to as a
Deadpool which was essentially an
ongoing bet on how long each of the
participants would live the reason for
this was due to the fact that the
experiments of Killebrew were sadistic
in nature and usually caused a patient's
in question to die in addition to this
an important distinction to make here is
that during his time as head of security
for kill GRU the inmates only knew Ajax
as the attendant but referred to him as
the a man and short another funny little
tidbit here for those who caught it was
that one of the new
rivals was named art Holyk and while Joe
Kelly never confirmed it
the running joke was that it stood for
Ren Hoek one of the main characters Ren
and Stimpy while this isn't wildly
important it does go towards a joking
nature of Joe Kelly within his own
comics but having said that the first
appears of Ajax in the story comes when
Wade attempts to commit suicide by
shooting himself in the head now for
those of you who have never seen any of
my videos on Deadpool something that I
want to point out is that his healing
factor had not manifested itself yet
meaning that as far as we know at this
point in the story
Wade is mortal and capable of being
killed but because the rules of the
workshop forbid the act of murder a jack
knocks Wayde out after which he takes
him to kill Drew's lab now this
particular part of the story is
extremely important in that it
establishes the nature of the workshop
and how it relates to weapon acts what
Joe Kelly tells us is that the workshop
functions isolated from the goings-on of
weapon acts as a whole and at the head
to the program don't know what's
happening now where Killebrew states the
facility is his own private playground
of sorts this is actually a lie and that
the actions of Killebrew would
eventually be discovered by weapon acts
and the entire program would eventually
be shut down but the more important
thing here is that Killebrew won't let
Wade die due to his need for test
subjects now this particular bit of
information is again important and the
reason why is due to the fact that after
his first session and recovering in a
cell weight is visited by mistress death
for the very first time now the cool
thing about this moment is that Joe
Kelly is providing us with some insight
into how mistress death functions
regarding those who are on the cusp of
dying in truth whenever characters die
in Marvel Comics they usually just pass
on and almost no information is given
regarding what happens next
while the afterlife has been depicted
various ways particularly in relation to
Jean Grey while she was a Phoenix force
with the exception of the original
Captain Marvel dying of cancer and being
S squared to the realm of death by
Thanos Marvel usually leads it to us to
determine how the process is taken
however in this instance Joe Kelly
simply depicts death as lingering around
those who are about to die and appearing
in the form of what makes the transition
easier in this instance mistress death
appears to wait as an attractive woman
since this is what Wade desires most at
the same time the fact that Deadpool can
see mistress death despite
not being dead comes as a surprise and
that this is not supposed to happen
however the reason for this anomaly is
revealed to be due to the fact that the
only thing Wade wants in the world is to
be spared his life of suffering and die
but because the actions of dr. Killebrew
keep this from happening mister steth
states that until it does Deadpool will
be made to suffer horrific experiments
unless he can find a way to end his own
life now focusing back on Ajax the
animosity between himself and Deadpool
is expanded on by Kelley when he tells
us that after his experience with Miss
Teresa death weight attempts to kill
himself several times where one instance
saw him attempting to use a fork and
another instance saw him trying to hang
himself each time his actions were
caught and stopped by Ajax but Deadpool
being sent to the lab of Killebrew to
this end
Wade's early hatred of Ajax wasn't due
to much to how he was treated personally
as much as it was due to the fact that
Ajax was keeping him from being with
mistress death and so after being
confined to a wheelchair and having his
arms and legs immobilized Joe Kelly
provides us with an expanse on who Ajax
is and what he's capable of what we're
told is that Ajax himself is a former
experiment of Killebrew and that his
nerves were removed to keep him were
feeling pain his mind was
psychologically conditioned to follow
orders and implants have been placed
throughout his body allowing for
enhanced strength speed and durability
furthermore after learned that Ajax his
real name is Francis and that he hates
that name did will begin stat on him
with it now the reason for way doing
this is to go to Ajax into killing him
however because of the rules of the
workshop unless an inmate dies
accidentally at the hands of killebrew's
experiments or kill drew himself
sanctions their deaths under no
circumstances can an inmate be killed by
Ajax or anyone else at the same time the
importance of Deadpool making fun of
Ajax is that in truth his authority is
being subverted prior to way deriving
the power of Ajax was unquestioned out
of fear that those who challenged his
authority would be taken by Ajax and
tortured for hours on end
however after Wade's arrival and because
of his desire to die he was essentially
a man with nothing to lose and no fear
of death meaning the anger he could make
Ajax the better chance he stood of being
killed and so taking the problem of dr.
Kiehl brew the case at Ajax makes here
is it the constant haunts of Deadpool in
the face of the other prisoners a Rhodes
Ajax's ability to effectively keep them
under control now the responsive
Killebrew is also very important and the
reason why is that Killebrew states that
the prisoners never respected ajax and
simply follow his orders out of fear now
the difference between these two things
is it rather than ajax operating as
someone who can ease the suffering of
the prisoners who in turn would follow
his instructions willingly ajax abuse
and taunted them meaning that like any
bully the one thing that he fears the
most is someone standing up to him and
usurping his power and so moving away
from responding directly to Deadpool's
taunts by punishing those around him the
focus of ajax turns to Deadpool's friend
worm now something that i hope you
notice here is that deadpool is not the
silly and goofy version of his character
that you may be familiar with and
instead is largely angry the reason for
this is that unlike christopher priest
daniel way or gerry duggan who largely
focused on the slapstick nonsensical
version of wade when joe kelly was
writing the character the emphasis was
on dark humor and less silliness an
aspect of his writing style that has led
some to claim that his run on deadpool
is the best but the actions of ajax here
are twofold the first is the punishment
of deadpool by making those he cares
about suffer and the second is in doing
so go Deadpool into killing worm for the
purpose of sparing his pain after being
lobotomized now this moment was
essentially the point when Wade's hatred
for Ajax shifted away from the fact that
Ajax was keeping him from mistress death
and simply focusing on Ajax as a mortal
enemy the reason for this was due to the
fact that while Deadpool had previously
killed people himself during his time as
a mercenary those individuals were
warlords dictators drug runners and
other kinds of criminals the more policy
of Wade is actually an adherence to the
idea that innocent people should not be
made to suffer for the actions of
another and that the cruelty displayed
here by Ajax and his willingness to hurt
innocent people was something Wade
wouldn't tolerate
however because mistress death had
appeared and coached deadpool into
euthanizing worm Wade had broken the
rule of the workshop the regardless of
his motives he had killed an inmate
meaning that Wade himself would be
sentenced to death now this moment in
the story is probably the most important
and the reason why is that it marks the
instance of Deadpool's healing factor
manifesting for the first time what's
also ironic about this is
Deadpool had been attempting to secure
his own death for quite some time or
goading Ajax into killing him but
because one of his friends have been
killed in retaliation by Ajax it had
actually given Wade a reason to stay
alive if for no other reason than to get
his revenge on Ajax and so after having
one of the instruments plunged into his
chest destroying his heart in the
process because his fate essentially
seemed sealed way to embrace his
mistress death under the belief that his
life will finally be a peace however at
the moment of his death and in the
process for Parenthood crossover his
healing factor kicks in and his heart's
healed now what Joe Kelly tells us is
that the healing factor of Deadpool
would never have kicked in had it not
been for Ajax the reason for this is
that after the death of worm Wade's
hatred became so extreme that it
overrode his desire to die jump-starting
his healing factor into action and
keeping him alive at the same time where
mistress death tries to talk Deadpool
into coming down and allowing his rage
to dissipate wait actually discards her
for a bit giving in to his will to live
and so taking to the armory and loading
up on guns and ammo that provides us
with his explanation of why he remained
alive despite having wanted to die so
frequently what he tells us is that
while death was his one pursuit after
one was lobotomize and Deadpool had to
execute him Wade was unable to forget
the image of Ajax smiling through the
whole ordeal
now with the actions of Deadpool leave
Ajax for dead allowing the other
prisoners to escape their incarceration
Joe kelly also tells us that Wade didn't
fully grasp the situation what I mean
here is that in the mind of Deadpool his
healing factor restoring his heart and
allowing him to kill Ajax was viewed as
temporary and the following his revenge
he expected to be reunited with mistress
death and journey to the afterlife
however within marvel comic's mistress
death is more of a ferryman than an
actual killer and that while she does
have the power to strip an individual of
their life essence this would result in
filming off the balance of life and
death as a result an individual has to
come to their ailment in order for
mistress death to take your spirit into
the afterlife meaning that because
nothing can kill Wade
reality itself will always find a way to
keep him alive hence the reason for why
he was thrown back in time to the
original Secret Wars event after the
incursion and the death of Deadpool
storyline
and so we're the comic shift is focused
back to the present day because the
story as it unfolded so far had been a
mental flashback of how Deadpool met
Ajax and death for the first time with
his physical body lying unconscious on
the ground
HX assumes Deadpool's death and simply
walks away not for Joe Kelly the issue
that he faced here was that with
Deadpool's backstory established and
Ajax introduced as the catalyst for his
healing factor the focus was split
between wrapping up the Ajax toy line
and determining whether age actually
remain as a major foe but because the
villain T ray had already proved to be
popular as Deadpool's arch-nemesis at
the time it made no sense to have two
main enemies for a single character and
so looking to eliminate Ajax and bring
the storyline to an end
Kelley provided a followup with the
escapees killed by Ajax appearing to
Wade and informing him that because
Deadpool swore on all that was holy to
kill Ajax a bond of sorts was forged
meaning that the spirits of those Ajax
killed couldn't rest until he was dead
while this is a flimsy piece of logic to
use as a follow-up and truth is actually
meant to be that way again
Joe Kelly always wanted to emphasize
comedy and action during his run rather
than using standard superhero themes
where Captain America were Avengers
comic would have seen the story conclude
with Ajax dying in the facility a
hallmark of Kelley's writing style was
using corny themes as a way to keep the
Deadpool stories going to this end
Kelley followed up to Ajax leaving by
focusing on his character and providing
some measure of the events that
transpired after the fall of the
workshop while Kelly doesn't give us a
lot to work with here what he does tell
us is it h axud kidnap dr. Killebrew
following his escape and it held him
prisoner now Kelly does not provide us
with an explanation of what led to ajax
amped up in a cybernetic form and in
truth he doesn't really mean to the
overall theme here is that following his
initial defeat by wade in abandonment of
the workshop much like Deadpool's hate
jump-starting his healing factor Ajax is
hate overrode his mental conditioning
allowing him to operate for the sole
purpose of tracking down and killing
Deadpool where he had believed his cool
to be accomplished in return to kill
brew the fact of the good doctor was
missing LED Ajax to realize that
Deadpool had actually survived and a
taken kill brew and so with the spirits
following Deadpool to ensure that he
makes good on his oath a final battle
ensues between the now cybernetically
enhanced age
sex and wave at this point we can
actually see the influence of standard
comic book storytelling in the comic and
that the battle between Wade and Ajax is
pretty run-of-the-mill what I mean here
is that within the realm of comic books
the best stories are the ones which
focus more on the emotions of the
characters involved more so than
outright conflict because this entire
arc had laid the groundwork for the
hatred between Ajax and Deadpool the
animosity is prevalent both within the
way that you relate to one another
through their words as well as their
actions at the same time and in an
effort to close up all loose ends with
Wade having saved Killebrew from the
hands of Ajax even if only for the
purpose of gaining his own revenge Joe
Kelly has killed Rou sacrificed his own
life as atonement for his past actions
while running the workshop now this
particular bid actually requires us to
delve into a little speculation here
because Kelly didn't tell us exactly
what happened between the fall of the
workshop in the present moment regarding
Killebrew we can probably assume that
when Ajax tracked him down some method
of torture was involved helping
Killebrew to see the error of his ways
on the other hand it is entirely
possible that he simply came to this
recognition of his own accord and look
to make amends but regardless of how he
came to this realization
Killebrew acts by setting a jerrycan on
fire using a flare attempting to burn
Ajax alive
however because of Ajax his physical
enhancements specifically his durability
and inability to feel pain the scenario
turns into a kind of Frankenstein's
monster situation and the Killebrew is
killed by the very creature that he
created at this point the story takes an
interesting turn with Kelly focusing
more on the intelligence of Wade rather
than his healing factor with a final
battle between Ajax and Deadpool left
Ajax injured on a physical level it
would stand to reason that this physical
appearance functions along the line of
cybernetic enhancements to modify as
already formidable strength using this
piece of knowledge and with circuits
exposed on the legs of Ajax Deadpool
plays possum allowing Ajax to tackle him
sending them both plunging into the
water below now while this is small is
also one of the hallmarks of Kelly's run
on Deadpool where writers like Daniel
way and Jeri Doug and do incorporate
these elements into the most recent
versions of Wade the intelligence he
displays during modern-day fights
comes across Morecambe - happenstance or
sheer luck instead of intelligence under
Kelly's time is right or however
he was never afraid to shy away from the
idea but Deadpool was smarter than the
average bear because of this Deadpool
was well rounded as a highly capable and
intelligent fighter who had a personal
moral code and a healing factor and so
because a cybernetic seed of Ajax is
essentially short-circuited but is also
more of a hindrance than a help due to
its weight
Deadpool uses this to his advantage
snapping a Jax's neck in the process
essentially killing him for good now
following this the character of Ajax did
make appearances in cable and Deadpool
number 45
Deadpool core number one and Deadpool
team-up number one but these appearances
came in the form of flashbacks designed
to reacquaint new readers with
Deadpool's history or simply came out of
a moment when he focused on the memory
of Ajax in truth Ajax his first
appearance in Marvel Comics following
his death came with deadpool vs Thanos
number two and number three and while I
have covered this full event here on my
channel which you can find in the
description the overall theme here was
that Ajax had essentially snuck out of
hell in an effort to kill Wade while
this would prove unsuccessful and the
fan OHS would blow him out of an airlock
and send him back to hell again this bit
of an inclusion was really just an
effort by writer Tom Seeley to pay
homage to the history of Deadpool by
focusing on one of his earliest foes
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys at her face